for people who are watching this
i think it's important because there's
aspiring radio personalities or people
who think they want to get into radio
who are watching this
and you and i keep having this
discussion about
our business and the future of it and
where it is what would you tell someone
like that who's
got zero radio experience but their
aspiration
is to be a radio personality like us
start to start with your platform now
build it build your platform
don't don't like don't wait for the
people don't
like wait for the right opportunity
don't go begging for a job build your
platform
start off like with your own like blue
leg cave podcasts or homegrown radio or
so many other entities that people are
doing you know what i'm saying um
the brilliant idiots joe budden pocket
whatever you want to build build your
own [ __ ]
and then take that somewhere to a
platform that might want the content
it's almost like because the old school
way of doing [ __ ] as far as like oh i'm
gonna
start as an intern and work my way up
that's cool that shit's almost dead
though but it's almost a non-non-it's
almost non-existent because
of the simple fact the way the industry
has changed it's almost like you gotta
already have some [ __ ] going on
especially i mean obviously we're in la
you know
we're speaking from being in market
number two that's fact so you it so
it's it's a lot harder to like think of
jason
from hollywood unlocked that's true
jason from molly over unlocked
had this huge platform they gave him a
syndication deal at iheart he's got the
weekend show him in damage
they already had some [ __ ] going but i
also say that if you're in
wichita kansas yeah you know i'm saying
if you're in wichita kansas
start your podcast and take your podcast
to the radio station like this is what i
do i would love to do that here or
whatever the case may be but have some
action items to show people don't just
go in
blind and be like hey i want you know i
want to here's my here's the burden of
training me
how to be a personality yeah i think
that people got to realize is
nowadays uh more than ever
those wichita kansas jobs are those
first of all they don't pay nothing
second of all they're
those those slots are dying
yeah i mean that's what i'm saying i
will say build your platform
you see you gotta be undeniable be
undeniable in radio you got to be
undeniable if you're gonna cut through
the the
bro you have to be undeniable
rowdy rich was a great interview too
yeah roddy was dope
yeah yeah right he's a perfect someone
who's undeniable be undeniable dog
yeah undeniable
well uh and then homegrown radio are you
guys still
doing um like the weekly podcast
so you guys started that in one year
2010 or 2011
20 we started doing homegrown yeah 2009.
oh nine in chuck's apartment and trucks
apartment
and then that turned into now you're
doing nights in l.a but
over the years that was like a thing
even if you weren't from l.a i remember
just you know i've always been tapped in
with what you do but like just being
like oh that [ __ ] is dope like like you
said like
you had your own thing and whether or
not
you guys would still do it if i heart
never stepped in facts